and we were witnesses to their
judgments. This is a story that
happened This is an occurrence
that took place with Dawud
Alaihi Salam. That is that you
individuals came to Dawud
Alaihi Salam and they brought
to him an issue, a dispute for
him to judge between them. But
one of them had a a crop. And
the other had livestock. And
during the night, the livestock
overran this crop. And, you
know, it destroyed it and ate
it and ravaged it. So, the
owner of this crop was unable
to unable to harvest it because
it was destroyed. It was
wrecked for the harvest time.
And so,
They wanted Dawood Alaihi Salam
to judge between them. Though
there would judgement was that
the person who had his crop
destroyed is owed the animals.
But the animals would be his.
So as they were leaving say
amen, Ali Islam was said to
have asked them what did my
father judge? They mentioned it
to him. And Suleiman's was
different. He mentioned that
They should trade places until
things go back the way they
were. Well, basically, the crop
owner is to take the the
livestock in question and
benefit from this livestock,
whether it be milk, the milk,
or the pull or you know, any
anything that he's this
livestock produces. And during
that time Epard is going to
plant the field the way it was
before and when the crops grow
to the to the size and general
likeness that they were before
this incident, they would trade
back. Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
says about this and we gave
understanding to Suleiman. For
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala chose
the verdict of Suleiman over
the verdict of Dawood Alaihi
Salam. But so that a person is
not confused with regards to
the of Dawood. Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala says and to each we
gave judgement and knowledge.
Yes, because Suleiman Alaihi
Salam was not his judgement was
preferable in this case. It was
chosen by Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala. Doesn't mean that the
judgement of Dawood is
is non existent or weak. Both
of them were very fine judges
whom Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala
used in good. Allah subhanahu
wa ta'ala said and to each we
gave judgement and knowledge.
And we subjected subjected the
mountains. That a word would be
subjugated. The mountains to
exalt along with David. And
also the
and the meaning of this is that
Dawood Alaihi Salam, when he
would pass by some mountains,
he may make Tasbir of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala and here
that the mountains would make
Tasbir. Glorification of Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala along with
him. This is more and beyond
just echo. This is not just
echo because that's not
particular to Dawud Ali Islam.
That's everybody.
this is a very specific type of
that these inanimate objects,
the mountains would make of
Allah subhanahu wa ta'ala along
with as well the birds. Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala says that
which translates to and we
taught him the fashioning of
coats of armor to protect you
from your enemy in battle. And
this is another blessing,
another miracle that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala gave to
Dawud. And that is that Allah
subhanahu wa ta'ala mentions
elsewhere in the Quran.
That metal or steel iron was
made soft in his hand and that
is that Dawud was able to shape
iron with his bare hands in a
way that a person could not
without out heat. Iron, wood
take the shape in his hands
that he preferred. Whatever
that shape was. Kind of like
Play Doh or dough. And so
Dawood Alaihi Salam it's
mentioned that he made little
rings. Little iron rings. And
he connected them. And this is
where chain mail came from. The
was given the ability and given
the know how to make the first
coat of armor and chain mail
for people to wear in battle.
Chainmail is again, it's like
you'll notice that long time
ago, medieval times, the night
will wear this shirt that's
made out of metal. called chain
mail. They'll usually wear it
under the hard armor on the
outside Anyhow, this chain mail
is more to protect a person
from blows, from a sword, not
necessarily to protect from
something that is a stabbing
motion. However, this later was
refined and throughout time,
throughout history. Armor, and
weapon have always been neck
and neck Even till now. We're
always trying to find a way for
the armor to be stronger than
the or to be able to withstand
the weapon and the weapon is
always being made better than
the armor and it's always
always in competition with each
other. advent of bun powder
different types of armor were
experimented with to try to
stop bullets and then when
burst vest, bulletproof vest
was brought forth, the bullets
were then reengineered to be
able to go through that vest
and the vest was later
reengineered to stop that armor
piercing bullet and the bullets
were later engineered and it's
always in competition which
with each other. The armor
always boasts its ability stop
weapon and the weapon always
boasts its ability to pierce
the armor and so Dawud Alihi
Salam a founding father of
modern armor. Then it goes on
in then Allah subhanahu wa
ta'ala goes on to mention in
more detail the story of
Suleiman Alaihi Salam which we
will get to tomorrow.
[Arabic recitation]